moza nation i wanted to give you an
inside look at one of our internal
company trainings where we talked about
personal finance and so i was asked by a
lot of people on my in my company uh to
do a training on this for them
internally
and we got a lot of good feedback from
it and so i thought i would share it
with you guys i got to sign off for from
my team and this is going to basically
explain to you how you can be in the top
one percent without having extraordinary
means of income and if you do have
extraordinary income then you should
definitely be there without making
stupid decisions all right and so uh in
the video i'm gonna be covering uh
different different things for savings
different things for investing different
ways to structure things um and all that
kind of awesome stuff so uh if you guys
don't know who i am my name is auction
mostly we own acquisition.com it's an 85
million per year portfolio i have
absolutely nothing to sell you there's a
lot of broke people out there and i
don't want you to be one of them welcome
to mozu nation i'll see you guys in the
vid
quick word from our sponsors before we
get going
there's this lovely book this is the
this is the
the the actual manuscript of uh 100
million offers
uh thanks to most of you guys on this
call it's the number one new release in
advertising so thank you um
when you get to the about halfway point
of the book there's one page that
reminds you to uh leave a review and if
you could do that it would be very
helpful because uh the more people read
the book the more businesses find out
about us the more business to find out
about us more sales we make the more
sales we make
the more secure everyone is and the more
jobs we can we can have and the more
clients we can help through our uh our
businesses by extension and so the more
we can change the world so um your book
review may indeed change the world uh
and so uh that is how meaningful it is
so please um go ahead and uh and and
grow the book it is 99 cents um if uh
if if that's too steep for you um then
don't get the book
so uh
without further ado today what i want to
talk about is personal finance
um and rather do a slide presentation um
sometimes
i want to mix mix it up um i have a
bunch of bullets uh and i think it went
really well with the gym ward so i
wanted to
kind of do the same thing and uh lately
and i talked about who's gonna talk
about what
uh because we both are involved in our
finances uh that's not always the way
you know in a lot of marriages you know
one person manages money one person does
other things but as
as resident cheapskate um of our
marriage it uh it made sense to have
personal finance full to me
and so uh i will kick this off kick this
puppy off with some stats and a quote
so quote number one the first 100 000 is
a [ __ ] but you got to do it i don't
care what you have to do if it means
walking everywhere not eating anything
that wasn't purchased for the coupon
find a way to get your hands on a
hundred thousand dollars after that you
can ease off the gas a little
charlie munger vice chairman berkshire
hathaway some of you guys may know this
but uh charlie munger is my probably my
number one resource for all things
wisdom and bunny and uh i actually think
he might even be a better teacher than
warren buffett i think warren buffett
just picked a couple of stocks that
ended up outperforming charles and
charlie has not had any like massive
home runs he's just been a consistent
investor for a long period of time um
and a general assault of the earth
individual who is full of wisdom and so
if you are looking for wisdom when it
comes to money i would i would recommend
anything that is written by him or any
talks that he gives what i want to
transition to is um the reason behind
this this kind of you know leadership
meeting a lot of times we talk about
management and uh you know leadership in
general and character traits and things
like that my goal in general as my life
has progressed is to make as many people
wealthy and independent as humanly
possible and so each of the businesses
that we've had have have done that and
there's different people who become you
know uh wealthy you know through jim
lords it's obviously our our clients but
i think as as i've gotten older my care
has actually shifted towards uh you guys
are employees of the company and making
sure that everyone here um becomes
independently wealthy and so what i want
to do is lay out a plan that literally
everyone in this call can become
independently wealthy if you follow it
is that cool with everyone is that all
right let's do it
yes absolutely like as a belief breaker
which is just like
everyone in any position in a company
right everyone has their compensation
levels that they're compensated at i
think something that um is really
interesting is that what i've noticed
over the years is that it's often not
correlated with how much money you make
let's correlate with everything alex is
going to talk about which is how much
money you don't spend
and so i've had personal conversations
with a lot of you who you know maybe
you're in the middle tier in terms of
compensation you have more saved and
more in your bank account less debt than
those who make more money in the company
and so i just want to put that out there
is that it's often you know getting rid
of the downside rather than increasing
the upside another quote for you
you cannot outwork money and so ideally
you would like money working for you a
horrifying stat is that the average
american negative net worth
literally if they were born
if you're born a baby and you have zero
net worth you're already in the top
you're already above average because
you've got zero
think about how [ __ ] wild that is
that's insane and that is because people
make poor choices not because of
anything else and so i want to be very
clear
about my my view on this and it's one of
victor rather than victimhood
we all make choices and independent of
what we make wealth is a ratio
of what we spend versus what we earn
therefore if you earn anything you can
become wealthy by controlling what you
spend so that's stat number one
step number two the average u.s minimum
wage worker will accrue over a million
dollars in earnings over their career if
they lived and worked a minimum wage the
entire time and never got a pay raise
which barely even makes sense because
with with every you know every four
years minimum wage goes up anyways right
so think about that for a moment
that means a million dollars is going to
flow through the hands of basically any
worker who works full-time throughout
their career in the u.s
all right
next one the median u.s income earner
will make over three million dollars
they will earn that over their lifespan
pretty wild right
what if we controlled the flow and we
actually made good decisions about that
lots of cool things and i will show you
that in a moment
and i want to reiterate one more point
and if you want to dot it underline it
highlight it
wealth is a ratio not a number between
what you earn and what you spend right
now there is something that is in your
life if you do not have the amount of
money you wish or you're not saving or
investing at the amount that you want
that is eating away at it it is your
number one nemesis
for some people it's sneakers
for some people it's eating out
for other people it's clothing and so
the question i have for you guys is
first off in the chat if you guys will
be open and honest with me
what is your vice
what is the thing that eats into your
accounts what is that thing that you
love spending on and you feel guilty but
you get that dopamine rush every time
you buy it
what is that
please put in the chat the more honest
we can be the better it'll be for
everyone high heels me too i'm with you
on that one right skincare eating out
kid stuff
food
food and beer okay cool fantastic this
is good nicotine coffee
got to be spending a lot of money on
coffee
alcohol a lot of people
drinking going to the bars going to the
club
right
there's a lot of things
and so the next question is um and this
is kind of why this is a behavioral
question because becoming independently
wealthy is not complex
it's simple not easy
and so my question for everyone on this
call is
are you willing to give up your vice
to be a millionaire the genuine question
i'll tell you a brief story um and then
i'll get into some of the more tactical
stuff and i want to make an example
because there are some limiting beliefs
around this that i think
need to be debunked wealth is accrued
through character traits
when i uh a lot of you guys may have
heard of the story of when i was
sleeping on my gym floor has anyone
heard that story the guy sleeping on the
floor didn't have enough money right
what you don't know is that i was making
five thousand dollars my second month in
business in profit the third month i
made ten thousand dollars the fourth
month i made third month i made fifteen
thousand dollars the next i made 20 the
next i made 25 the next one made 30 the
next made 35 and that was in profit
and i was sleeping on the floor and that
was because for me i get tremendous
amount of anxiety
if i spend any amount of the income that
i earn that is not negligible
and so i wanted to take as much of that
money that was coming in and adding it
to my bank account and so for me and for
everyone here if you can gamify that one
simple number
which is what is in your bank account
you will win the game
and so many of you are not in complete
control of your finance because you also
have a spouse
and so we will we'll distribute this to
you guys so if you want to play this
with your spouse because maybe by the
end of this call you decide to make some
decisions i'd like to get them brought
in as well because you have to do it
together right not one of you can do
this you both have to do this together
if you are married but if you do commit
to this and you can play a game which is
the game is how little can we spend
and see if you can beat your last
month's total every month see what else
you can trim see what else you can not
spend money on because it becomes fun
and interesting and as soon as you can
make not spending money fun i promise
you you will have more money than you
ever need you'll be able to eliminate
the stress in your life around money
and i mean this so sincerely from the
bottom of my heart everyone here in this
company can become independently wealthy
can become the top one in america simply
by the habits that you choose to make
today like i i'm serious as cancer right
now and i wish i could tell better
stories that i knew how to break the
blues and we can do this
um and i'll try and address them at the
end because some of you will have
limiting beliefs around this but if you
make the steps that i'll walk through
today um
they will they will benefit you and
there's only six steps that i'll walk
through they're very simple and they're
very straightforward okay
now
next next little stop on our adventure
okay
is let me show you
the eighth wonder of the world does
anyone know what the eighth wonder of
the world is so let's say marcos how old
are you you can unmute if you want to
just tell me he said
fantastic
want to see some crazy [ __ ] marcos
because i'm about to show you let's say
you have zero dollars saved up
okay i don't know what you got saved up
but let's say you've got zero dollars
saved up are you curious by any chance
how much if you saved 100 a month you
would have by the end this is not the
actual amount
are you curious do you want to know how
much you'd have if you saved up 100 a
month and you just put it in the s p
between now and when you're 75
yes
you're curious you want to see very
2.7 million dollars pretty [ __ ]
interesting right yes very
i would agree with you
so check this out
let's make this zero this is something
that i have saved on my phone this
calculator i have saved on my phone and
so right now let's say that you're
looking at making
uh a jordan's purchase right you see the
new jordans and you're like man them
shits are sexy
so you take your hundred dollars and you
think well
i could either have these jordans or
when i retire i could have twenty two
thousand dollars
which would you prefer
the 22 grand
i i agree with you i would as well i
made similar decisions throughout my
life
now if you looked at going out to dinner
for example or going out to lunch and
maybe just going out to lunch three days
a week right it's an extra let's say 12
bucks a day right three times a week so
it's 36 bucks times four so you're
looking at like 130 140 bucks just by
not eating out
31 000
damn and that's just one month
now if you did that for a year
you'd have 400 000
wow
i agree with you but no one does the
[ __ ] math
that's crazy i've never thought about it
that way that is the purpose of this
call
thank you marcos yeah thank you
you bet and so one of the number one
things that happens and one of the
limiting beliefs that people have is
that the amount that i can save right
now is not enough
it's not enough to make a dent it's not
enough to do damage now some of you on
this call might not be 19 years old and
have you know 60 years of compound
behind you right so let's look at let's
look at what probably the median age in
this company is which is 35 years old
okay
and so let's be a little bit more uh
aggressive here let's say again you
start at zero
but you decide to start saving 500 a
month i know that's aggressive but let's
just say if you did you'd be able to
retire with three million dollars it's
100 bucks a week the thing is is that
just about everyone here if you make
different choices about how you live
what you spend your money on
you would be able to have this outcome
and i mean generally from like the
bottom of my heart it's just like
fitness right you have to you have to
burn more than you than you eat this is
simple eat less than you burn or yes
exactly thank you saving money and
personal finance are simple except the
thing with weight loss is you don't have
any compounding thing that's working
with you right with money your money
works for you right while you sleep and
so that's the magic of this and here's
what's cool marcos
i will show you something interesting
they may be like how is that even
possible how can i say 500 a month from
now being 35 until 75
well you only contributed 240 000 here
i mean that's a lot
but this is how much your money worked
for you
which is why you can't not work money
you have to let money work for you
and so the number one thing that will
create wealth for everybody here is your
income that is the thing that will
create that that is the flow
right obviously throughout the company
you can look at different opportunities
to make more money to to you know to get
promoted to to add more value to the
company and things like that so you can
increase your inflow
but for just about everyone here and
what's kind of funny is that i have had
many conversations with people and i
want to be really transparent here
there are people who make the most in
this company are among the most i would
say the top 10 earners in this company
who i've had conversations with who have
zero dollars saved up
i've also had conversations with people
with the top 10 percent earners company
who have negative net worth i've also
had conversations with people who are in
the bottom 20 in this company they don't
have higher net worth
than the people in the top percent 10
and so to me that shows that it's choice
it's just a choice and i can tell you as
somebody who's made this phenomenal
amount of money throughout my life
my level of well-being has been no way
affected
by anything that i've spent money on
material goods do not increase my
acceptance of subjective well-being
and so if you're if your goal is to seek
to decrease the anxiety that you have in
your life because of finances then the
easiest way to do that is to spend less
money because you have lower risk
consider your fixed expenses and your
lifestyle your risk basis this is your
risk that you have as an individual and
so if you can make yourself an
investment that has very low risk and
very high return you will reap the
benefits over a long period of time
and so this again is assuming you save
a month
that's it
now let's just get wild and let's say
you go all in on this and you just you
just go nuts and i'm going to give you
some of the habits and all that kind of
stuff in a second but i just want to
paint the picture first
so let's say you did the same exact
thing but you were like you know what
i'm totally changing my lifestyle i'm
downgrading where i live i'm selling the
lease on my car and i'm buying a car and
five thousand dollars in cash that i
have no payments let's see where this
takes us
2500 bucks a month it's 14 million
dollars
just in case you're curious that's not
the top one percent
that's the that's the top point four
percent
of the united states
and you just get there through making
smart choices
and this again is assuming you have zero
dollars saved up so this is for you
marcos let's say you save twenty five
thousand dollars by the end of this year
because you do a great job and you live
like a cheap ass all right and you put
no more money in for the rest of life
all right and you start because you're
19 years old
that's how much money you can have 5.5
million dollars if you just save 25 000
today and put it in the s p and never
think about it again marcos you could be
hood rich
right
and so one of the things does anyone
here know what the number one drain on
net worth is
besides taxes 35 of every single
american's paycheck goes to this one
thing yes
laura larose
interest 35
so for context
imagine right imagine where you had a
franchise right and so i i own i'm the
franchise pro subway i have i license
out my business model too 10 000
restaurants
subway gets 10
and they kill their franchisees because
there's no margin in
food do you know who's killing them
three and a half times more
the banks
35
of the average american paycheck goes to
interest
that's it
and so right now what i just showed you
was 500 a month so can everybody here
just for just for shits and giggles
multiply what you take home by 0.35 put
that in that calculator i'll wait for
you guys to do it multiply what you make
by .35 and put that in as your monthly
contribution you can start with zero
dollars you put 75 as your retirement
age the reason you do that is because
we're all going to live a lot longer
than our ancestors did
so why you guys are doing that and
getting that calculation and the reason
i'm asking you to do this because i want
you i want to show you that it's worth
it
to make these decisions
and so
the reason 35 percent
is that for example let's say you buy a
house
right you've lit you you're realizing
the american dream which is hilarious
because you didn't actually buy a house
you got a loan because the banks have
zillions of dollars of advertising to
make you to fool you into believing that
is now the american dream is that you
owe them money that's the american dream
is that you owe someone else money and
that 35 of your paycheck goes to them
for the rest of your [ __ ] life you
could also get into student debt which i
abhor and heat to like every ounce of my
being but i won't even get into that so
let's just talk mortgages
if you do
buy a house and you're the average
american and you move in three years
which is what the average american does
they move every three years do you have
any idea what percentage of all those
quote mortgage payments that you're
making are going towards principal which
means the actual amount of the house
dominic correct you have a 30-year
mortgage your first three years you're
paying jack [ __ ] towards your principal
which means
you just leased it from the bank and
then they get somebody else in and then
they and they and 97 of the dollars that
go in there go to them and the bank
holds the note on everything to the same
degree if you buy a car
and you can't buy it in cash
the same interest applies except it's
even higher isn't that wild isn't that
nuts
what's what's more is that for those of
you who have uh student loans
think of how crazy this is
they lobbied to get the government
to back
student loans which means they gave 18
year olds so everybody who's on the
sales team understands this but if we
try and give a business owner get a
business financed right in real terms of
the likelihood that they pay back the
debt
for even fifteen thousand dollars right
the approval rates like one out of three
for 15 grand
and yet because the government allows
this
they allow banks to give a loan for 200
000
to an 18 year old with zero [ __ ]
earning potential
and they say that they can never get out
of it which means that that percentage
of your paycheck what they did just like
that subway that road say off the top
they're getting a royalty on your
[ __ ] life
35 of everything you make forever
and they allow people who aren't even
old enough to drink
put themselves in enough debt they can
never get out of now i believe in
personal accountability you should be
responsible for your decisions
but i don't think you should be
subsidized back by the government the
purpose of today is hopefully to shock
you a little bit into how much many
people on this call are being robbed by
decisions and the invisible hand that is
taking money from your pocket every
single month and so if you guys will let
me i would like to walk you through six
steps to get out of this mess is that
okay with you guys so you saw the sunny
side which marco's got to see you can be
worth six million dollars if he just
saves 25 grand this year and doesn't do
anything else on the flip side
for everyone else right not just marcos
hopefully marcus you don't have a
mortgage and student loans and all the
other things right hopefully
for everyone else
you can see what has been robbing you
and your ability to create generational
wealth is this one thing and so my goal
is to get us to get this
this
this monkey off our backs and so one
more one more stat that i will that i'll
push towards you
is that does anyone hear anyone willing
to be honest that is anyone here have
credit card debt does anyone have credit
card debt okay so who here know has hurt
you know like compounding is the eighth
wonder of the world which is what
marcos's eyes popped out of his head
when he saw the noun right eighth wonder
of the world is compounding
you can also have negative compounding
interest
which compounds against you
and so you have
the eighth wonder of the world beating
you up every single day rather than
lifting you up so that you can become
financially afraid that is the eighth
wonder of the world working against you
because it's compounding and for many of
you you know credit card debt 10 12 16
per year if you could get it if you
could get a an investment that'd be 16 a
year you'd be [ __ ] stoked
and that's what exactly what every
single bank did in the world is they
make you the investment that they get 16
percent compounding in we cool is
everyone like do i have everyone's
complete attention what i want to hit on
are the the six the six pieces here all
right
number one
is that you have to
start saving money
and
you do that before you start paying debt
off all right you're like how much do i
save
what you save is something called an
emergency fund
and the reason you start there rather
than paying off your debt is because
something will come up and if you learn
the habit
of stopping to pay off your debt you'll
stop paying it off it's like going on
vacation and so think of this as the
vacation fund for your financial fitness
is that we need to plan for the vacation
that's going to come so that we don't
get off base for most people
that emergency fund is between one
thousand and five thousand dollars
i will let you decide on on what that is
based on your income
but what that is is when your carburetor
and your car goes up or when you break
your foot and you have a service it's
the stuff that is quote unexpected but
100 predictable that it's going to
happen at some point in your life and so
the idea plan for the thing that you
know will happen you just don't know
when
the only variable is when not if
and so has anyone here i'll ask this
question to prove the point can i just
get hands you can see it on the screen
has anyone here in your life had an
unexpected bill come up
so then can we call them unexpected
let's call them expected bills and just
plan ahead all right so the first thing
that we do so if you're writing this
down the first thing you do is you save
between one and five thousand dollars i
will let you make that decision you are
grown-ups that means that even if you
have your credit card debt even if you
have other things that are stupid that's
fine for right now the first step is to
save one to five thousand dollars
step one step two
you pay off all your debts
minus your mortgage so if you have a
mortgage don't worry about the mortgage
for now we'll get to that in a second
except for the mortgage you pay off all
your
and it is my my two cents
that it's better to pay off the smallest
debts you've got
even if you've got one that's let's say
20 and you've got another one that's 10
and the 10 one is smaller despite it
mathematically making more sense to pay
off the higher debt one
no one here has made any [ __ ]
national decisions up to this point so
why would we make them now
the point
is that we need to get the emotional
victory we need to lose some weight we
need to tighten our belt all right and
you need the first win so that you can
see that you can do this and so you pay
off the smallest debt first and then you
pay off the second smallest debt and
you'll feel is momentum and you'll see
that you can do it and so what my
earnest ask is that if you can team up
with your spouse on this and you show
them how much money you could be making
with just what you're paying in debt
right now
35 of your paycheck and how it can be
create independent wealth for you and
your family for the long run
just by doing this then hopefully it
will make it worth it more than getting
a dessert at chili's although i do love
desserts at chili's i think they're
fantastic do it when you can afford it
and you can pay for it in cash and still
hit your bunch to show you to the extent
how much layla and i believe in this we
bought our home in cash we bought our
cars in cash everything we pay for in
cash we have zero debt total zero
and what i can tell you is it feels good
knowing that no one can take your [ __ ]
away from me because for those of you
who like to be more sophisticated and
read up on articles on crypto and robin
hood let me tell you an interesting
concept that i learned from somebody
who's much wealthier than me they said
debt
increased risk risk if expanded over a
long enough time horizon
will eat away the returns that the
additional leverage gain
because anything
any number no matter how big multiplied
by zero
is still zero
so it doesn't matter how good you are
and how much you saved if you take on
too much risk which is what debt is
over a long enough time horizon it will
multiply you by zero which some of us
are old enough marcos you're not but
some of us are old enough to remember
the 2008 2009 collapse i will tell you
that just about every entrepreneur
friend that i know lost everything
they start back at zero
and marcos
you saw that you're at 19 and if you
didn't [ __ ] up if you don't [ __ ] up
between now and when you're 75 which
means you don't take on debt and you
just you need to pay for things in cash
and you budget how much you make right
and you spend less than what you earn
you'll be able to be financially wealthy
for this your life you'll also never
have to worry about money
ever and the only reason people don't do
this is because they think that status
and how good they feel about themselves
live in the eyes of others rather than
their own eyes would you rather be rich
or have everyone think you're rich it's
a real question and most people answer
by their actions which one they'd rather
actually want which is why finance and
personal finances is much more a
question of character than it is about
intelligence is anything here complex
that i've shown you
a earth arithmetically save more
than you earn
right spend less than you earn
do it for a long period of time
don't buy [ __ ] you can't afford and no
money to do it i told you step one save
one to five thousand dollars step two
pay off your debts smallest to largest
not in terms of interest do it in terms
of smallest to largest for many of you
that may take one year two years or
three years and i know that this is the
that's the rocky cut scene
that's the part
of the movie that everyone fast forwards
through but i can tell you that the
amount of spiritual growth that happens
when you consistently
live disciplined will change who you are
and how much control you perceive that
you have over your life and you may
lament the fact that you have student
loans you may limit the fact that you
got into a 30-year mortgage we'll talk
about in a second but those things are
done there's nothing you can do about
this all we can do is the choices that
we have in front of us and so the
question is are we going to let the
decision that we made years ago
rob us of the future that we can have if
we choose to have it one save one to
five dollars
two
pay off all debt that is not
not
your mortgage in terms of smallest to
largest you paid off just you know as
soon as layla and i started making money
we paid off her student debt
right
like we live by this this is i believe
this falls to bones through and through
all right
third step
in your in your piece of in your inner
financial freedom is actually expanding
your emergency fund
those savings
you don't invest those
those are just so that you can live as a
human being and feel safe
some of you will have larger need for
security
other of you will have smaller needs for
security and so the range for this is
three to six months of living expenses
now the fact that you've done this after
you paid off your debt aggressively you
will already have the character traits
in the discipline to know how to live on
less which means you're very able to one
you won't even have to save that much
because you already have been living on
so little
so three months might not even take you
level and you would be amazed at how
much more money you have when you have
no debt that goes out every single month
paying the banks
you will be blown away so right now
for shits and giggles because that's why
we do this right chasing giggles nothing
here is serious as cancer right
except for you know your future and
everything else
shits
who here has a car payment you get a
hand you have a car payment
okay
who here
leases where they live or has a mortgage
now if you were to add that amount of
money up
remember that calculator i want you to
put that in the calculator again
i know i'm asking you to do some more i
think it's worth it can someone throw
some numbers of what that would equate
to 2.1 million dollars there it is and
just so you know no one can guess what
your car payment and your house payments
are based on this number so don't worry
about it six million dollars 3.2 million
dollars 5.6 million dollars 3.8 million
dollars so
2 million dollars 15 million 1.5 million
dollars 2.8 million
how [ __ ] nuts is this
this is the [ __ ] they don't tell you
this is how everyone at the top makes
all the money they loan people who can't
afford things things they can't afford
and they saddle them with that that's
compounding against them for the rest of
their lives that's the secret
so if you don't want that working
against you these are the hard decisions
right now if you can have the hard hard
conversation with your spouse
and think to yourself
is there a way because now at this point
in the in this process
you can
try and pay off where you live so that
that money that you're currently
outflowing becomes your retirement fund
you could literally do nothing else you
could just do that
and
and
own the car you have in cash and just so
you know as somebody who's had supercars
and had a prius that was worth five
thousand dollars it gets me from point a
to point b in the exact same amount of
time it was also the biggest regret of
my life is buying the the belly that we
had number one financial regret i have i
get zero enjoyment out i miss our little
broken prius that a dense a dent on the
side door and had a crack through the
windshield
and for context just so you guys know
that i'm drinking my own kool-aid
when we owned that car as the only car
that layla and i split
we were millionaires and i had a lady
who was in our mastermind named monica
patar who saw us pull up to our
mastermind in the prius with a cracked
windshield and the dents in the door and
she said i thought you guys were
supposed to be rich
as she walked into the mastermind which
you as of course a guru are horrified by
this kind by this idea and i said i am i
said you should look at my bank account
and so that's the kind of thing that
just like it just gives you what kind of
confidence do you want do you want
someone to say nice car or do you want
to bait let's say you should look at my
bank account there's a kind of
stress-free living there's a kind of
confidence that comes from this there's
a kind of [ __ ] you money energy that's
hard to fake and i would like that for
everybody here on this call and it is
100 attainable for everyone here
just making the right choices
so the number one the easiest thing you
can do is if you have a lease you can
turn it in early and you can buy a car
for five thousand dollars in cash you
could save up for it okay but once you
do that remember that hundred dollars a
month
that two hundred dollars a month that's
some of you guys are paying as soon as
you save up you that one time
that two dollars a month becomes a
constant flow that for the rest of your
life is adding towards your net worth
and then you can choose to downgrade and
not live in the really ritzy fancy
neighborhood that you live in now that
might be above your means or rather is
above your means because you can't buy
the house in cash and you're just
loaning it from the bank right
and this is stuff that no one says it
everybody wants to you know impress
their parents to show them what
neighborhood they live in
rather than impressing themselves and
giving themselves a stress-free life
again for context when i did decide to
lease my first spot where i decided to
live if you guys are curious i split a
bedroom in a house
bedrooms i split one bedroom with one
another guy i paid four hundred dollars
a month in rent and this is in southern
california
for anyone who has contacts 400 a month
gets you nothing
i split a bedroom in a house
and again i was making twenty thousand a
month
and i'm not saying i'm saying this
because i believe in this so thoroughly
and very luckily on my part i was i was
raised by a father who came to the
united states with nothing
he was an immigrant he had one thousand
dollars that he was able to take with it
and so we'd split the paper towels in
half
right because we didn't want to you know
waste them we never use napkins because
those are expenses used housed the
dinged table
right you saved everything we always
would get like two milks at costco which
were like big-ass gallon ones and it was
just me i was the only kid and he's like
drink up it's gonna go bad
because he didn't want to buy the milk
at royal farms or 7-eleven whatever you
guys have it was like a dollar more all
right
and that's why if you guys can gamify
this with your spouse you'll win the
game because if you can play the game
you'll win but most people just don't
realize that you are in the game right
now and other people are playing you
so
i gave you the first habits
one to five thousand of emergency and
you do that before you pay debt because
something's going to come up and you
don't want to break the cycle of paying
off your debt so you do that first
then you start paying off your debts
from smallest to biggest all right so
you can get the emotional victories and
you start winning
number three then you save up three to
six months of living expenses so that
you can feel financially secure so you
don't have to worry this will lower your
stress and will make your life much
better the point that most people have
of becoming wealthy is because they want
to become happier the easiest way to
become happier is become less stressed
the easy way to do that is save some
[ __ ] money fourth step
this is where you look at how you can
start building wealth all right and so
the way to do that if you have a
mortgage and you don't want to live
somewhere else
renegotiate the mortgage you can
refinance right now
because right now interest rates are
nothing and try and get a 15-year fixed
that will make your mortgage go up but
the vast majority of the money will be
going towards something that you own and
so your principal will start you will be
increasing your net worth
fun fact you don't pay capital gains on
selling the house that you own so if
your primary home
increases in value and you live in it
for over two years and then you sell it
and decide to go upgrade because it's
gone up and you can buy 100 of your new
house with the cash that you have saved
up you don't pay taxes there are some
things the government has done to help
people out that is one of them
so if you insist
on on living somewhere that is beyond
what you can currently pay in cash
then refinance to get a 15 year fixed
and then when it comes to cars if you
can combine because most you guys work
from home well most of you everyone here
works for mom
you probably only need one car and if
you're like no way it's like lately and
i live with one car we still live with
one car actually [ __ ] now we have to but
like we lived with one car for a very
very very long time right and i'm about
to return because i don't need to so if
you can buy a car in cash which there
are tons of good cars in cash and here's
what's crazy cars in cash that you buy
and you use for three years thousand
dollars you can sell for five thousand
dollars you just use it for free
pretty well
all right
everyone ready for five step five all
right step five's exciting step five is
where you invest 15
of your pre-tax
pre-tax income
into the s p 500
again i am not an investment
professional i do not recommend that you
listen to me in any way you should
consult your own professional advisors
for any investment advice uh and this is
not a recommendation
at all because i don't know what i'm
doing and so you can make your own
decisions as an adult uh to choose to do
with your money what you want to do if
you look at the last 80 years
of the s p 500
it's gone up by about 9 to 10 per year
for that entire period of time now if
you guys haven't heard my talk on
volatility and risk it's good to
understand this
the reason we built up the emergency
fund of three to six months of living
expenses is so that you never look at
that money and that you never stop
putting money into it and i will tell
you one story that you guys know half
the story about and for those of you who
are about to read the book you're going
to read the first half of that story
which is that i went almost to bankrupt
and i had a thousand dollars left in my
bank account right before i started gym
watch what you guys don't know
is that i had just under 300 000 saved
up
that was in an index but to me
and you can tell by the way that that
story was wrote
that money does not exist
once it is gone it is gone
you never see it again you never touch
it don't look at it
and if you need to make money you find a
way to make money you sell something you
work an extra shift you take up uber on
the weekends whatever
the point is you don't touch it
because if you can learn that character
trait you can learn not to put your hand
in the cookie jar you see the money that
marcos can have if he just puts ten
thousand dollars away or twenty five
thousand dollars away
mark goes i see something really crazy
let's say you save 25 grand this year
and let's say because you're like alex
i'm all in on becoming independently
wealthy let's say you save 2 500 bucks a
month all right because you hustle your
ass off selling
here's what's [ __ ] crazy
that money that 74 million
is being made
it's just the question is whether you're
going to be the one who makes it or the
bank that money's being made either way
think about that
money is being made all day every day
all the time the dollars always work at
the same degree for whoever their master
is
the question is whether you're the
master of the dollar or the person
you're paying and if yes you're curious
about like what the tactics around this
are all you do is you download robinhood
which is the app which is free connect
your bank account and you can you can
deposit straight into an index off there
it's very straightforward you don't need
an advisor they're just going to charge
fees which are actually going to kill
your returns so don't worry about it
s p 500
again this is not investment advice do
whatever you want with your money
in fact i might not know anything so i
definitely i would say don't listen to
my bus
right
this makes sense for everybody
i'm gonna go through the steps one
through five again from the top
one
save one to five thousand dollars
because that is the guaranteed fund of
something that's going to happen to you
you just don't know when
number two you pay off your debts in
order of smallest to biggest not in
terms of the number how much money how
much what percentage it's earning at you
pay in terms of how little you have to
pay it so you can eliminate it and just
start crossing out line items all right
step two
step three
you save up three to six months of
living expenses
it's up to you depends on your risk
tolerance marco can probably save three
you don't have kids or a wife if you've
got kids and a wife you might want to
save up it's up to you step four
you look at what you're living with
so if you have a lease on a car
trade it in
get a 5 000 car and live on that period
if you can downgrade where you live and
what neighborhood you live in do it
because i can tell you we just saw how
35 of your check is going to make
someone else 74 million by the end of
your life
it's just up to you whether you want to
make it or you want someone else to make
it step four actually that was step four
uh if you if you insist on living
continued step four step four b if you
insist on living in the same place as
you live now
then
refinance for a 15-year fix that way
you're gonna get the vast majority of
the one that you're paying is gonna go
towards the equity of the house and not
to interest fees and if you do that
you'll be like whoa
the amount i have to pay for month is so
much more it's almost like you're
actually trying to buy it
fifth
invest 15 of your pre-tax income
pre-tax you have to do some math here so
if you make 50 000 a year
you multiply that by 0.15 which is 7 500
and that's what you save
that's minimum you can do more than that
do more than that get aggressive with it
right
and if you want to be a superstar let's
say you do that 15-year fixed and you
invest 15
you plow the rest of the excess cash
that you have into that equity so you
can pay it off early
you know make sure that you have no
prepayment penalties
so maybe you pay your 15 year fixed off
in 10. and then in 10 years here's
what's crazy
you have no car fee you have no house
fee you've learned to live on far less
than you make
and now everything beyond the food you
eat goes into building your wealth
everything
and you'll be you will be frightened to
see how fast it grows
and i will share one more fun fact for
you guys today
right now
layla for this year made more money on
our money than we did from our companies
and i'm being transparent about this
because i want to show you
that it's possible
you also if you read the book see that i
had a thousand dollars on my bank
account saved up
and when i started my first gym i had
four thousand dollars total
you can do this
it just takes discipline
it just takes making choices where you
look marcos that pair of jordans instead
of seeing a pair of jordans you see
twenty two thousand dollars
that's what you have to see when you see
go getting beers with the boys on the
weekend for 20 bucks right
of course you wouldn't do that because
you're 19 and that's below the legal
drinking limit so the non-alcoholic beer
that you get because you're a crazy
person why would you drink up
non-alcohol beer you weirdo anyways so
you go get your nine alcoholic oh duels
right for 20 bucks and instead you see
that that's six thousand dollars
six thousand rk speed very expensive so
just about everyone here has been
drinking top shelf their whole life they
just don't know that okay one thing alex
that's from yes i was i was about to
wrap up and open it up so we're good
okay cool
um something that um you know because
alex and i obviously you guys are
probably like well you guys own the
companies you know you have lots of
money like are these things there's a
few things i want to point out which is
one when we first learned about money
and money as attention was when we were
literally like we had it was when we
first tried gym launch we went almost
bankrupt like in credit card debt like
all that stuff that's when we got a
coach who taught us a lot about money
and one of the biggest things that he
talked about was the attention of money
the attention of debt and so with the
first paycheck i got from when alex just
paid me like an employee when i had made
all the sales in the gym in hawaii i
paid off all my debt with that and so
the reason for that was like i only had
a very small amount left it was just
like the attention that was going
towards that debt right the second thing
with that is the same is true with
things that you accumulate and this is
something that we've gotten the
opportunity to learn as of more recently
like we had one car we had a small
apartment we had all these things when
we first started the companies and over
time you think well there's such a large
discrepancy between how i live and then
what i have that maybe i can fill it a
little bit and then what happens is that
you have attention on those things
because if you get a car that's more
expensive maybe you can afford it but
it's the attention it takes because
that's like for an example a toyota you
take into the shop takes a week to fix
we have a car that's in the shop right
now it's been eight weeks has been fixed
right things like that that become
complex even though it doesn't need to
be and so it's not even just the things
that you're buying with money it's the
attention you get back when you start
saving the money so for example i used
to tell people when they would come into
the gym they'd be like i'm in debt and
i'm overweight in the snack i'd be like
well you have your nails done your hair
down your eyelashes like why don't you
just get those things on we're like
they're like well i don't feel good
about myself because of those things
right i do those things to feel better
about myself i'm like but the reason you
feel bad about yourself is because
you're in debt and you're fat so what
the hell and so i think that a lot of
times those things that are like vices
for example cover like a short-term pain
fear anxiety insecurity we have but it's
actually just piling into the long-term
one and so it's like in the short term
it might feel worse to save that money
but in the long term you'll have way
more attention and way less anxiety if
you do
so i just want to share that i think
it's even if you have the money to get
stuff
stuff adds complexity which adds more
anxiety and so it's like we all want
more money so we can have stuff but then
you just feel worse anyways so it's just
it's just ironic
was this guys was this valuable for you
guys
this was different than leadership and
management stuff and how to run meetings
which are all very important as well but
my goal is if i can decrease the stress
of everyone on this call by helping
everyone make good financial decisions
then you know eventually we can operate
as a company of people who are not
stressed
wouldn't that be nice
because we realize that no matter what
we're secure and we know exactly what
our expenses are we know exactly how
much we earn and we know that we make
far more than we spend
and we also understand that we are 100
in control of our finances and so my my
plea to you is that if you've ever felt
like someone else is in control or you
feel like you've been dealt the [ __ ] at
the stick right you drew the short straw
that no one [ __ ] cares
and it's still up to you like no one's
gonna come to save no one's gonna come
to sleep but the good news is that
what you need to do in order to become
the one percent in case you're curious
one to five million dollars in assets is
the one percent
that's it
and we just showed marcos here how to do
that with twenty five thousand dollars
and so anyone here if you're like man
but i've got i've got but i've got but
i'm different you're not just stop
you're not
you're not
my metabolism is different really you've
solved obesity we can just cure africa
from starvation because your metabolism
is special you've figured out a way to
not eat food and still gain weight
we have to put you in a lab so we can
crack
malnutrition we can just figure out the
genes that you have that somehow cause
you to not lose weight when you stop
eating right somehow you've cracked
arithmetic and somehow figured out a way
to spend
even to somehow lose money and go into
more debt despite
spending less than you earned
all right like you're not special the
math is the math right
and so i just like i wanted to do this
call because it's important to me that
everyone here on this call can use jim
launch to become your financial vehicle
for wealth and ever can do that minimum
wage
makes a million dollars over their
lifespan and i showed you the
contribution of the five dollar a month
person it's 240 000
and it created three million dollars so
the question is do you want to look like
you live like a king or actually live
like a king and i think that living like
a king comes from the peace of mind that
you get and for me that is how money
serves me so because you have to figure
out how many serves you or whether
money's serving you at all
but that 74 million dollars that marcos
has the potential to make
over his lifespan that money is being
made the question is whether or not you
want it to be you who makes it all right
my sermon is over
you got five minutes left i'm gonna hold
you um otherwise thank you guys for your
attention and um if you guys do get a
chance uh grab a copy of the uh
our sponsored our sponsored book 100
million offers you can find it on amazon
in the link and if you feel uh so
compelled to leave a uh leave a review
uh that's good then please do so if you
hate the book then please don't leave a
review um
anyways lots of love guys uh appreciate
you all thank you so much for for being
on this journey with us i hope that we
can all use the well-being that we help
gym owners uh succeed with and we can
also use the income that you guys have
to set yourselves free as well because
you can do it easy catch you soon
hi